let's go back to Kelly Clarkson okay we
go in Philly yes she will be spinning in
her coaches chair when the boys returns
tonight on NBC and also back Jennifer
Hudson and you know what that means
ken does that mean double trouble for
Blake and Adam females have won the last
two seasons and then you have to contend
now with Jennifer who comes in she'll
toss a shoe and I feel like once that
happens is a wrap for you guys it's a
wrap for you it really is well I'm not
upset not upset because I like girls I
mean and so when they win it's you know
congratulations I'm happy about it as
long as it's not Adam I don't care J
HUDs return is about to shake up the
coaches panel on the voice there's just
one problem
she's really hard to hate look I can't
compete with that and also she's like an
Oscar that's like after we did promo one
day like I had to follow her and let me
pay to do these ads really kind of act
and I'm like are you freaking kidding me
I have to follow the Oscar winner like I
was so intimidated I want to pee my
pants and honestly y'all she's like the
sweetest thing ever
she and her favorite always be like
cookies in pot or her there's a very
important decision for you to make the
right one her name is Jennifer Hudson
joining the coaches for season 15 or
mentors Thomas Rhett CeeLo Halsey and
Keith Urban did you get to meet Nicole I
think I have said hi to nicole maybe
once in my life in an award show
she didn't come with Keith to rehearse
much to the disappointment of myself and
my team because she's really the only
reason I invited Keith to be my mentors
because I wanted to meet Nicole Kidman
wanted to hang out with her he said I
had to sit there with freaking Keith all
day for no reason
hey he got a woman listen and a good one
because you don't need another reason to
love Blake Shelton okay but I'm gonna
give y'all one anyway here it is when
Stefani will show you it's what she
wants me wait a minute a singing cowboy
did he say turning me on like it's her
job working overtime
[Music]
[Applause]